JEFF: I'm a big guy,
so I didn't think that a current
could actually push my body
the way that it is.
♪
The most challenging thing
about being in this current
is to be at the mercy
of Mother Nature
and allowing the current to
take you wherever it takes you.
Except for into the coral;
that's no good.
♪
But once I took a breath
and focused on moving my body
with the current,
rather than fighting it,
I started feeling more confident
in what I was doing.
I'm finally able
to control myself,
and I'm rewarded
with an absolutely amazing
underwater experience.
♪
And that was the tightest
I've ever went
through any coral reef.
They were just everywhere.
♪
Just gliding through it
and seeing the walls
on each side of us.
I've never seen anything
like that before.
♪
There was so much marine life.
This coral was one of the dopest
things I've ever seen,
but navigating the current
was kind of hard.
Whoo!
And showed me that being
in rougher waters
with these fast-moving
whale sharks
is definitely gonna be
an intense challenge.
♪